hi Gary Lauren you're here from shark
tank I always say I can tell instantly
something as a hero or a zero but I'm in
the wine section here and I can't tell
what is the difference between any of
these wines help me Lori
first of all thank you so much for the
question big shout out to all the sharks
that I've been mingling with the sharks
lately look Lori I think everybody has
this problem I think that buying wine
when you're trying to figure it out
you're not gonna be able to make a
judgement on the label buying wine based
on the label crushes my soul buying wine
because the shelf talker says 90 points
is the secondary move that crushes my
soul though Wine Library does that at
scale and we put up those Shelf dollars
because it sells wine I think the best
thing you can do is form a relationship
with your wine person and have them
really learn your palette over time
that's gonna work for you seventy eighty
percent of time because you're not
always gonna be by your local wine shop
or that person might be sick that day
but uh I think the the best move in lieu
of the wine person is to try a different
varietal every time you go by
recognizing that trying a Gewurztraminer
or a Marcin or a ruse on or a lyric or a
or a Gruner Veltliner or ala Grine try
you know corn Oz trying these different
things right
blough Frankish like just trying new
stuff it's always a great way to go
you're scared that you're gonna try
something you don't like but again it's
really no different than the advice I
just gave about facebook video when you
haven't tried something you can't judge
it got it and so the value of trying
something and creating the context
content is King context is God something
I'd love to say this is another version
of it you've got to try new stuff so
build a relationship Steve you know my
palate what do you got today are weird
you know you're recommending a pinot
Tosh from South Africa cool I'll try it
but no Steve he's sick today try some oh
I've never had you know anything from
Lodi before or I've disregarded buttery
Chardonnay is for five years let me try
another one just to see where my palate
is and where those shards are in
California these days so mix it up
it'd be very unlikely